he goes you want to know what something
is and I leaned in and I was like
[__] yeah I wanna know what something is
he goes all right then
next time your dick's hard I was like
wait what
hold on a second man
we've been talking about odometers all
this time
and now you got my dick hard and I don't
know how you're gonna roll that back
and he got mad he goes you wanna know
what's up man and I got scared I was
like yeah I'm sorry but please I need to
know what something is it goes all right
there
next time your dicks hard
put it in your left hand
then put your right one over it
he goes if there's anything still
sticking out of the top that's something
got the [__] out of the car and I never
saw him again
[Applause]